all right this virus has reshaped our
entire word creating a pandemic which is
forces to change our routines and
rethink our immediate future Sports is
trying to get back into our lives but
positive test for koban 19 keep throwing
us for a loss over at UNLV a simple hash
tag has organically exploded on social
media and if enough he'd the hash tag
there may be college sports this fall
have you ever met somebody who's created
a hash tag that has grown from coast to
coast in a matter of days UNL B's
athletic director Desiree Reed Francois
is that person she was driving by a
Legion stadium with her teenage son who
asked her if there would be fall sports
and I said well Jackson we're gonna play
if we can play it safely and it's
critically important that we all wear
our masks from this tweet face masks for
fall sports a hashtag movement was
hatched universities across the country
joined in from Buffalo to Central
Florida Penn State Georgia Tech TCU all
over the West Boise State Washington
State Arizona State and the list goes on
and on
UN are joining the movement the main
sign in every state should read wear
masks especially if you're hoping to sit
in a stadium my student-athletes our
coaches and all of our staff are working
so hard they're dying to play and if it
means wearing a mask we'll do it stats
don't lie just like masks saves lives so
thanks to you and obese athletic
director a simple social media tweet
might simply help fans get back in the
stands this fall we really want to play
fall sports and a face mask to help us
get there that's what we're going to do
all right we'll see what happens
coaching